[Music]
previously on Lord of the Rings
middle-earth rules say that a falling
wizard can catch up to his falling sword
and falling Balrog even when those
things have a 20-second head start
I know golems not exactly smart but why
would he talk so loudly to himself if
he's trying to actually sneak up on the
hobbits and surprise them Sam is
addicted golems have a union of the two
towers roll credits
oh wait looks like meat is back on the
menu for about 10 orcs the other ones in
the background appear to be happy with
their maggoty bread
I was gonna save you now there is no way
that one of the Riders of Rohan was able
to throw his spear from this distance to
kill a crouching or make it look like
the character died when 90% of the
audience knows he didn't die cliche
right sunrises this night as Legolas
serious so every time blood spills a red
Sun rises so there should be a red Sun
for like at least half the trilogy right
I know we need to establish that Legolas
has become a blood brother to Gimli but
this is way out of line for his
character and stupid I mean is this
Legolas Skywalker yeah now spice the
first clue should have been when we
hail'd you while your backs were turned
and we had no reason to give away our
position instead of asking the riders if
they remember killing people as
memorable as hobbits or if they even
remember snacking to small childlike
creatures who don't look one bit like
orcs on the death pile eeeh Murr chooses
the all I remember is that everybody
died story to keep us in quote-unquote
suspense in five seconds Gimli finds a
hobbit belt in an orc stack I agree that
err going is this badass Ranger dude but
the hobbits track should have long been
trampled over by horses and men dragging
dead orcs to the flaming death mount
first off the nazgûl really need to stop
shrieking and giving away their position
secondly you tracked Frodo to the
marshes and once again can't locate the
ring mere feet in front of you also a
closed fist is enough to quiet a
powerful magical evil ring this forest
dissolved how old is it
how the hell does this actually work how
did they not see them
[Applause]
Wow the flag waited until the perfect
moment to break her spirit
I guess Gandalf used a Jedi mind trick
of some sort to make this guy forget
that he was a wizard and that the
walking stick was a magical staff
Gandalf clearly walks into the hall with
a staff out in the open and it's not
entirely hidden as he continues to walk
towards the king but nonetheless it's a
total surprised agreement when Gandalf
exposes the staff to show he means
business it's the staff the sole source
of Gandalf's power didn't he lose the
staff and fall with the Balrog for days
and days and fight that demon with a
sword this fall would kill some people
and break bones and pretty much anyone
except Grima Wormtongue I agree with the
merciful Aragorn here you shouldn't just
go around killing dudes but why should
he be let go
also they didn't have to give him a
horse did they you have 2,000 good men
riding north as we speak does this look
like 2,000 men
where did error go and learn to count
when last I looked
Sandin not Aragorn was king of Rohan
yeah well last I looked
Theoden got his kingly mind all invaded
by the evil sorcerer
so maybe shut your piehole would let
someone who hasn't completely do the
planning oh she thinks she's move on it
is a dangerous road to take is there a
place in all of middle-earth except
maybe the Shire that isn't dangerous
when you walk through it Andy Serkis
isn't getting nominated for an Oscar in
this scene I realize marching to Mordor
must be brutally boring but none of
these soldiers looks up to see the not
really even hiding hobbits most useless
love triangle in the history of plot I'm
pretty sure Legolas can shoot arrows
faster than this but I guess we need
more time to get acquainted with the
wargs hey you know I believe a lot of
things in these movies magic talking
trees immortality evil spirits but in no
way do I believe Legolas got on this
horse in the manner depicted who them is
that and is not Gimli
even the middle-earth horrible creatures
been on death would rather bark at you
than try and kill you first for the
third time in the series and the second
time in this movie yet another character
supposedly dies when we know full well
he doesn't where is he felt you had no
chance anyway cliche elms deep has one
weakness helms deep was built with the
same flaw as the Death Star tens of
those
but my lord there is no such force this
is a great reveal for the audience but
you can't seriously be expecting me to
believe that Wormtongue either lives in
this tower or comes here every morning
for work and has no idea there are tens
of thousands of soldiers outside did
this movie just turn into ferngully
degree view then to learn that he is
dead
how does we're in trouble fast enough
for Faramir to know that Boromir died
alone in the forest but not fast enough
for that message to also contain the
words by the way don't kill or capture
the to ring bearing hobbits that were
friends of your dead brother Boromir who
enter them the big fool pays the penalty
of death
the forbidden pool are you making this
up as you go along
discount Kristen Stewart well that's a
foul wait didn't we just see them do
this already I mean I know airhorn said
hold after the old dude accidentally
shot his arrow but this hold mean don't
fire where does it mean everyone put
your bows down completely so that I need
to give you an entirely separate command
in order for you to raise them again by
Kevon he's just now telling them this
that guy must be half elf half will have
the instinct forever to do anything why
because the story's not ready for them
yet but it doesn't want you being all
surprised when they show up later ok so
speak English then all the ents nodded
when you made that you aren't orcs
Proclamation so all of you understood
that
who had one job Legolas one job no one
could possibly fall for the Aragorn
likely dead routine at this point but
the movie keeps wasting time on it POW
distri bird not know this felt the trees
talk to each other wouldn't the ents
have gotten word that this was happening
well here we are at Helm's Deep the next
morning where's that red Sun that
signals the blood spilling that Legolas
was talking about this asshole probably
still can't detect the ring
I am a mr. Murphy's waiting
[Music]
it's to be sighs magic Matt look at me
let's leave my my size do you hmm
and where you should not it's the castle
of the Wicked Witch
Dorothy's in that altered place oh I
hate to think of her in this we've got
to get around don't cry now you haven't
got the oil can with us and you've been
squeaking enough as it is
[Music]
in any fight it's the guy who's willing
to die who's gonna win that inch and I
know if I'm gonna have any life it's
because I'm still willing to fight and
die for that inch